[Musique]
dimanche matin il y avait beaucoup de
course ce week-end mais nous on est dans
l'est pour le trail du bassin boeuf 27
kilomètres près de 900 m de dénivelé à
la découverte d'un territoire magnifique
des terres agricoles des rivières
splendide
vous allez voir ça va être top
[Musique]
non seulement déjà c'est pour faire
découvrir justement d'un territoire nous
sur twitter il ya un beau site
c'est une personne humble il ya bassin
buzz va signer quoi c est ce qui est
vraiment qui c'est agréable mais ça
roule donc pour le début de la
préparation intéressant après ouais mais
aime bien le site quoi bassin des faits
puis
[Musique]
pourquoi ce que c'était que mon premier
prime premier trail ouais bon
félicitations génial alors quel goût ça
mais ça l'est devenu à la fin
[Musique]
27 minutes les premiers sont moins ça
commence à appliquer mellal et qu'on
remonte est magnifique on est bientôt à
la vanille rey à savoir faire un
patrimoine photo peut être fier on va
voir ça de suite
[Musique]
on peut être très fier de cette famille
réunionnaise puisque c'est à la réunion
que l'on va trouver le procédé de
pollinisation de la fleur grâce albius
mais c'est aussi à la réunion qu'on va
découvrir le procédé de transformation
de la gauche qui permet de garder tout
son arôme à l'intérieur et ça c'est
david de fleuriste un producteur de
saint-andré qui va trouver la solution
en 1857 et choses épatantes c'est que
depuis 150 ans on n'a rien changé aux
procédés qui était mis en place par deux
fleuristes en 1857 les vanille de la
réunion ont de tout temps été primés
dans les concours etc
tout simplement parce qu on a un terroir
qui est excellent pas c'est à dire qu'on
essaye toujours d'améliorer la qualité
de notre vanille et pour ça on travaille
notamment actuellement sur les terroirs
de la réunion tout comme le vin on aura
des notes différentes en fonction des
zones de production il faut savoir que
les vanille que l'on produit à
saint-philippe n'ont pas tout à fait le
même parfum que les vanille de sainte
rose ou les vaniteux saint-andré et nous
c'est ce qu'on est en train d'étudier
actuellement ici à la vanilleraie donc
si vous venez vous trailer découvrir la
vanille sur notre site vous pourrez voir
tout ça mais ça s'est repris la course
mais c'est après la course bien sûr
vous êtes le malheureux de la route
[Musique]
roger kg mais personne n'en fait
j'habite dans le champ de canne beau
chalet veux pas qu elle n pour toutes
les bourses et je sois balade union chef
du gouvernent la compagnie
c'est quoi une photo merci c'est le
bassin de l'année prochaine passant il
fait beau c'est toi tu les encourager
[Musique]
ce qui est génial le bassin louise
agents de cannes comme ça c'est l'odeur
l'odeur du sud de la can
le matin c'est top
[Musique]
non
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je crois que ça y est on a retrouvé la
rivière 6 et 4 passes un peu ce qui fait
que la route
un joli à laval c'est bien
[Musique]
il est autour de ça
c'est pourquoi vous fera de lui le
pouvoir va faire plaisir
sauf pour la forme il plaisir le plaisir
surtout
et à chaque fois on a formé le plaisir
[Musique]
après le bassin boeuf la fougère langue
de boeuf
[Musique]
mais ça nous les noirs quoi décote
décote super encore un petit peu à
descendre tu poser la question au début
toujours bien mal au dos ou avec la
descente ah merde
ouais mais bon c'est là tu sens que tu
vis ouais c'est là que tu sens qu'il
travaille les odeurs le bruit tout
change pour c'est qu'on approche de la
ville et que la course est bientôt fini
c'est terrible ça c'est pour pas faire
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au gros soleil pour conclure cette aire
de travail spécial bassin bosse tous les
territoires mérite est découvert c'était
génial
c'est ce que vous avez passé un bon
moment la rumeur et sentiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]